So one of the arguments in the manosphere
is that women have much higher expectations for men
than men do for women. We think that men want the boss, babe,
and they want us to pay bills
and they want us to cook and clean and have kids,
when in reality, that's not what they actually want.
Men have become discouraged within the dating realm,
rightfully so, because they seem to be viewed as a walking,
talking checklist. And nobody discusses this walking checklist
that men have to live up to
better than Gerard Butler and the Ugly Truth.
Women would have us believe that they are the victims,
that we break their hearts for sport.
They say they want true love,
but all they want is a checklist.
Is he perfect? Is he handsome?
Is he a doctor? For you,
men who fit the criteria, don't get yourselves,
cause they're not sleeping with you.
They're sleeping with a carefully calculated set of venal choices.
Money over substance, looks over soul,
polish over principles. No gesture,
no matter how real or romantic,
will ever compensate for a really impressive list of credentials.